I'm joined today by Amy Julia Harris
who's an investigative reporter for
reveal from the Center for Investigative
Reporting for the past year she and her
colleagues Shoshana Walter have been
investigating abusive drug rehab
programs around the country including
some that forced the participants to
work for free so Amy it's great to talk
to you you know I've been covering the
sort of scamming nature of some rehab
programs in the sort of for-profit world
and there's of course nonprofit and
for-profit drug rehab programs but you
focus specifically on this issue of
participants effectively working unpaid
at some of the the programs in which
they're supposed to be receiving
treatment first question is how did this
even get on your radar that this was
going on yeah we started looking into
this when we were put on the state court
speed and sort of told to find stories
in court systems anywhere across the
country and we got really interested in
diversion programs and drug courts and
it started with a pretty simple question
where were these diversion programs
sending defendants for drug and alcohol
treatment and what we ended up finding
was that a lot of these drug rehab
programs were a little more that worked
camps for private industry and drug
courts and other people in the criminal
justice system were sending defendants
there because these programs marketed
themselves as free so a lot of
defendants who are in the court system
did not have a lot of money did not have
insurance license to rehab programs had
incredibly long wait lists so courts
said here's this great alternative to
keep people out of prison but a lot of
these nonprofit rehab programs were
exploiting people is what we found out
is in exchange for a sort of free drug
treatment people were supposed to work
at for-profit industries and then turn
over their paychecks to the drug rehab
center and that was supposed to pay for
their treatment but we what we found out
at a lot of these centers was there was
no sort of recover
or addiction classes or treatment it was
just non-stop work sometimes 12 16-hour
days for days on end and people were
just working for free and a lot of
people describe it to us it was sort of
like a slave camp and modern-day
indentured servitude okay so let's get
some of the sort of basics down is this
primarily happening at the suppose you
know not legally net designated as
nonprofit rehab centers is it happening
at a mix of for-profit and nonprofit
centers we found for the most part it
was nonprofit rehab centers many of them
were religious we found one in Oklahoma
that was called Christian alcoholics and
addicts in recovery and it prided itself
on not taking any state or federal
funding and the idea was sort of that
participants the program would pick
themselves up by their bootstraps and
work to pay for their stay so it's a
non-profit rehab program and they were
turning over all of their paychecks to
the nonprofit so these these rehab
centers we found out sort of operate
almost like temp agencies that they have
a contract with a for-profit company and
then all the participants in the drug
rehab program go and staff the companies
we found that people were working and
chicken processing plants manufacturing
plants doing really really often
dangerous and very physical jobs and
then they would just turn over their
paychecks to the nonprofit rehab center
I I hate to necessarily make this
comparison but it's fresh in my mind
because I recently read Jeff Quinn's
amazing book about Jonestown and Jim
Jones so much of what you uncovered
mirrors the way that the Jonestown
Peoples Temple operated which was they
brought people in who would turn over
their paychecks some of them would get
supposed addiction treatment from the
sort of pseudo Christian perspective
that the Jones temple subscribed to they
would also sometimes operate nursing
homes because of the way in which they
operated
sort of being slick with licensing and
and how that all had to happen they
operated at very low cost not actually
paying anybody and taking in people's
Social Security money and other sources
of revenue I mean so much of what you
described rings to me so similar to what
was going on with in the noir in
Northern California that Jim Jones was
doing and I'm guessing that part of the
way that it works Amy also skirts
regulation and labor laws as well yeah I
think I think that's an apt comparison a
lot of people that we talk to you
described some of these programs it's
very cult-like we just published a story
in North Carolina about a program called
recovery connections community which is
a two-year long residential rehab
program and participants went there when
they were usually at the end of their
rope they didn't have insurance they had
nowhere else to go many of them were
coming from state-funded detox
facilities or straight off the street
and they went into this rehab program
and then they were forced to work for
free in adult care homes as caregivers
for elderly and disabled people so you
had recovering drug addicts who had
almost no training who were changing
diapers for a really vulnerable
population and sometimes even dispensing
drugs that led to their addiction in the
first place so what we found obviously
in this the scenario things went wrong
all the time
found that these rehab participants for
stealing drugs from the assisted living
facility in several cases were accused
of sexually assaulting patients at these
adult care homes and this this just
reminded me of what you were saying was
that a lot of people that we talk to you
describe this rehab program more than
some others as very cult-like the only
sort of therapy that they would get was
every week they would be put in a circle
and someone would be in the hot seat and
then everyone else in the rehab program
would yell at them about their
flaws it would get incredibly abusive
there was a lot of profanity and people
we talked to said this was all about
control sort of breaking them down and
then turning them into sort of puppets
who would go to work and then turn over
their paychecks and they they said that
you know it was a lot of it was very
brainwashing and and that they were open
to that because these were people who
had nowhere else to go and they were
sort of in this incredibly vulnerable
time in their lives where they were
looking to get help and you
unfortunately have a lot of these people
who are preying on that and sort of
making money from from people who don't
have other options is there any reason
to suspect that the criminal justice
system and this could be like a specific
court in a particular place it could be
individuals within some of these systems
it is anybody even potentially getting a
financial kickback from some of the
rehab centers because you see a lot of
mandated and negotiated participation in
these programs in lieu of prison
sometimes for example what about the
possibility of kickbacks being sort of
in the system it's a good question and
we we haven't found that actually what
we have found was that many different
states particularly drug courts and
diversion programs have strict rules
that say that courts are only supposed
to send defendants to licensed rehab
programs for treatment so that's a role
on the books but what we found was a lot
of times the license to rehab programs
have incredibly long wait lists they
have you know nine to ten months until a
bed opens up and then court officials
just say okay well something is better
than nothing we don't want to send
people to prison so they turn to these
unlicensed programs even though that's
technically illegal and against the
spirit of many of these laws in
different states so we we found that it
was a little bit more a marriage of
convenience than any sort of corruption
a lot of judges thought that people they
sort of had this this sense that people
should take responsibility and
go to work and again pick themselves up
by their bootstraps and try to get
themselves clean and the overriding
thing that we found that in a lot of
course is that there's sort of you know
as as criminal justice reform is
sweeping the country everyone is looking
for alternatives to incarceration and a
lot of these work based rehab centers
are sort of riding that wave and
marketing themselves as a great
alternative to prison to the courts and
courts either because they they are not
aware of the rules or sort of have have
found that a lot of these license to
rehab programs have long wait lists have
sort of shrugged and said okay
somethings better than nothing and then
they're funneling people into these
programs that are often open to abuse so
how do these programs not get shut down
I mean how how are they skirting what we
would think of as licensure licensure
laws labor laws whatever it is that that
there could be a case made if a normal
employer so to speak was doing this how
are they getting around it all yeah we
found that a lot of these programs are
unlicensed and it comes down to sort of
a technical jargon a explanation if you
describe yourself as a Recovery Center
or a 12-step peer support Center in
North Carolina that means that you're
absolutely exempt from licensure and
what we found out is at least for the
program that I was describing earlier
recovery connections community state
regulators sort of helped them avoid
licensure and coach them to say look
there is this licensing exemption and if
you describe yourself in this way we
can't touch you and a lot of people who
have issues a lot of these rehab owners
that have us kind of sorted paths take
advantage of that so we found that in in
this program recovery connections
community the owner of this rehab
program in the past was an administrator
at a different rehab
program that was licensed but she got
into a lot of ethical problems she ended
up sleeping with one of her rehab
participants using people in her program
to perform personal favors for her
rather than having treatment she would
force them to sort of babysit her kids
and wash her clothes and clean her home
she was stripped of her therapy license
fired from that rehab center and then
she just sort almost overnight started
this different unlicensed program by
just describing herself as a Recovery
Center and nonprofit peer support center
so a lot of a lot of what we found it
comes down to sort of a technical
marketing of yourself and a lot of a lot
of states just just have very poor
enforcement of the rehab programs we
found that in Oklahoma for instance
there was a rehab program that was
sending defendants to work for free and
chicken processing plants that program
was unlicensed because it sort of had a
faith-based exemption and this idea that
these recovery centers were a great
alternative to prison and state
lawmakers didn't want to want to create
too many standards for these types of
programs to pop up they were afraid that
if they made the licensing process too
arduous if these programs would not
exist and people would be funneled into
prison so often it's sort of just hoping
that everything's going well and then
these programs market themselves in the
specific way and state regulators just
don't do anything until they are really
really serious abuses extraordinarily
disturbing how we've been speaking with
Amy Julia Harris is an investigative
reporter for reveal from the Center for
Investigative Reporting really great
work and I appreciate you telling our
audience about it thanks for having me
on